are you by any chance uh aware of uh
the hutter prize marcus hutter
he uh he made this prize
for compression
of wikipedia pages
and
there's a few qualities to it
one i think has to be perfect
compression which makes
i think that little quirk makes it much
less
applicable to the general task of
intelligence because it feels like
intelligence is always going to be messy
uh
like perfect compression is
feels like
it's not the right goal but it's
nevertheless a very interesting goal so
for him intelligence equals compression
and so
the smaller you make the file
given a large wikipedia page
the more intelligent the system has to
be yeah that makes sense so you can make
perfect compression if you store errors
and i think that actually what he meant
is you have algorithm plus errors and by
the way hooter hatter is a he was pa er
he is the advisor of schoenleck who is
the mind
deep mind co-founder yeah yeah so
there's an interesting
and now he's a deep mind there's an
interesting uh network of people he's
one of the people that
i think
seriously took on the task of what would
an agi system look like
i think for a longest time
the question of agi was not
taken
seriously or rather rigorously
and he did just that like mathematically
speaking what would the model look like
if you remove the constraints of it
having to be uh
having to have a reasonable amount of
memory reasonable amount of running time
complexity uh computation time what
would it look like and essentially it's
it's a
half math half philosophical discussion
of uh how would it like a reinforcement
learning type of framework look like for
an agi yeah so he developed a framework
even to describe what's optimal with
respect to reinforcement learning like
there is a theoretical framework which
is as you said
under assumption there is infinite
amount of memory and compute and there
was actually one person before his name
is solomonov hooter extended
solomon of work to reinforcement
learning but there exists a
theoretical algorithm which is optimal
algorithm to build intelligence and i
can actually explain you the algorithm
yes
let's go let's go
so the task itself
can i just
pause
how absurd it is
for brain in a skull trying to explain
the algorithm for intelligence just go
ahead it is pretty crazy it is pretty
crazy that you know the brain itself is
actually so small and it can ponder
how to design algorithms that optimally
solve the problem of intelligence okay
all right so what's the algorithm so
let's see so first of all the task
itself is
described as
you have infinite sequence of zeros and
ones
okay you read n bits and you are about
to predict n plus one bit
so that's the task and you could imagine
that every task could be casted as such
a task so if for instance you have
images and labels you can just turn
every image into sequence of zeros and
ones then label you concatenate labels
and you and that that's actually the the
and you could you could start by having
training data first and then afterwards
you have test data
so theoretically any problem could be
casted as a problem of predicting zeros
and ones on this infinite type so
so let's say you read already n bits and
you want to predict n plus one bit
and i will ask you to write
every possible program that generates
these end bits
okay so um and you can have you you
choose programming language it can be in
python or c plus and the difference
between programming languages
might be there is a difference by
constant
asymptotically your predictions will be
equivalent
so you you read and beats you enumerate
all the programs that produce these end
bits in their output
and then in order to predict n plus one
bit you actually weight
the programs according to their length
and there is like some specific formula
how you weight them and then the n plus
uh one bit prediction is the prediction
uh from each of this program according
to that weight
like statistically you statistically
pick so the smaller the program the more
likely you you are to pick the its
output
so uh that's that algorithm is grounded
in the hope
or the intuition that the simple answer
is the right one it's a formalization of
it yeah um it also
means like if you would ask the question
after
how many years
would you know
sun explode
uh you can say hmm it's more likely the
answer is
to some power because it's a shorter
program
yeah
and other
well i don't have a good intuition about
how different the space of short
programs are from the space of large
programs
what is the universe where short
uh like run things
uh so as i said the things have to agree
with end beats so even if you have
you you need to start okay if if you
have very short program and they're like
a still some has if it's not perfect
with prediction of n bits you have to
start errors what are the errors and
that gives you the full program that
agrees on end beats
oh so you don't agree perfectly with the
end bits and you store
that's like a longer a longer program
slightly longer program
because it contains these extra bits of
errors that's fascinating what's what's
your intuition
about
the
programs that are able to do cool stuff
like intelligence and consciousness are
they uh
perfectly like is is it uh
is there if then statements in them so
like is there a lot of exceptions that
they're storing so um you could imagine
if there would be tremendous amount of
if statements yeah then they wouldn't be
that short in case of neural networks
you could imagine that
what happens is
they
when you start with an uninitialized
neural network
uh it stores internally many
possibilities how the uh how the problem
can be solved and sgd is kind of
magnifying some some uh some paths which
are slightly
similar to the correct answer so it's
kind of magnifying correct programs and
in some sense hdd is a search algorithm
in the program space and the program
space is represented by
you know kind of the wiring inside of
the neural network and there's like an
insane number of
ways how the features can be computed
you